j'aime beaucoup vous parlez de tablette
de samsung les dernières j'ai présenté
la table 6 la galaxy tab à 6 on a eu la
galaxy tab est 5e et là on va parler
d'un modèle version light de la galaxy
tab et 6 c'est la galaxy tab s6 lite
vous vous en doutez c'est ce petit
modèle à petit oui et non il a néanmoins
un joli petit stylet elle fait plein de
jolies promesses elle les tient dans
l'ensemble c'est un très très bon
compromis un très joli produit que je
vais vous détailler aujourd'hui
mais avant toute chose si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas je vous invite à vous
abonner à la chaîne pour tout savoir de
l'actuelle confites également deux
guides d'achat de tutos d'astuces et
compagnie vous avez le bouton de saut je
vous invite vous pouvez y aller la
première chose qu'on va voir c'est le
format on est sur quelque chose de pas
trop trop grand qui se prend très bien
en main ce soit dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
un produit avec une très bonne
expérience lorsque vous souhaitez
l'emmener avec vous un hespel convient
poser très facilement qu'il ya une
attache magnétique un format qui est
bien qui est compact mais surtout avec
de très jolis finition lorsqu on
pourrait dire produits light finition
like qui vient là non c'est pas du tout
le cas vous avez un dos en aluminium qui
est vraiment très sympa qui par contre a
la fâcheuse tendance je ne sais pas si
vous en rendrez bien content comme ça de
laisser quelques traces de doigts c'est
une tablette qui fait 465 g qu'on va
retrouver en deux couleurs ici j'ai une
couleur grise qui existent également
bleus il ya une couleur rose mais par
contre si vous êtes en france eh bien
vous ne pourrez pas l'avoir peut-être
dans votre pays vous avez la couleur
rose mais dites le moi ça en bas en
commentaire donc voir point de vue
global en termes de prise en main
découverte de matériaux on a quelque
chose qui est extrêmement bien fini on
n'a pas produit au rabais et ça croyez
moi on cherche à avoir une tablette
milieu de gamme eh bien ça aussi toute
son importance
la qualité de l'écran est assez bonne
ici pas de dalle amoled comme ce qu'on
avait les dernières sur la galaxy tab
est 5e ou encore mieux sur la galaxy tab
est si si on se contente d'une dalle tft
mais qui je trouve à un rendu qui est
assez qualitatif
il faut dire que samsung maîtrise
vraiment saidal vous avez un écran de
10,4 pouces de diagonale résolution 2000
pixels par 1200 pixels à 225 pixels par
pouces un écran qui occupent 80 1,1 pour
cent la face avant d'un wii fait
extrêmement précis la luminosité n'est
pas dingue je me suis mis en extérieur
pour l'utiliser j'ai privilégié les
zones d'ombré néanmoins je voyais quand
même pas mal
ici on nous annonce une luminosité
maximale de 400 vite quand on va acheter
une tablette qu'elle soit milieu de
gamme ou très haut de gamme c'est
toujours extrêmement important c'est
d'ailleurs un des points les plus
importants d'avoir une qualité
d'affichage qu'ils soient irréprochables
en ici on n'a pas les
dernières technologies on n'a pas de la
molette néanmoins leur dalle tft elle
marche bien
les couleurs sont justes le rendu est
correct pour regarder des films des
séries vous ambiancer devant youtube
tout ce que vous voulez eh bien vous
avez de quoi faire l'audio est aussi
bien maîtrisé avec des haut parleurs
stéréos il y as kg vous en avez un de ce
côté là et vous avez son petit frère ou
sa petite soeur comme vous voulez qui se
situe de l'autre côté ce qui fait que
lorsque vous prenez votre tablette comme
ça vous vous mettez du contenu
multimédia
eh bien vous avez une sensation de
spatialisation beaucoup plus immersive
on a du soc est assez fort c'est pas
ultra ultra forme et ça marche
en plus de ça vous avez un autre point
qui est bien c'est la présence de la
charge de schubert à chaque fois elle
est juste là la plage année je me
planque
c'est ici là vous avez une petite cerise
diack donc si vous souhaitez utiliser un
casque avec une prise jack vous les
branchés dessus et bien vous pouvez le
faire
donc ça c'est bien et vous avez en plus
du bluetooth 5.0 vous permettra de
connecter un casque sans fil vous avez
également du dolby atmos où je trouve
que l'expérience audio et bien et ça
bien augmenter l'expérience purement
multimédia la performance n'est pas en
reste on se retrouve ici avec un exynos
n'a fini 611 c'est ce qu'on retrouve
dans les smartphone milieu de gamme
notamment le galaxy à 51 vous avez 4
gigas de ram c'est là le pdr 4x si on
veut rester à plus d'un côté technique
sinon vous avez 64 giga de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 1 tera on n'est pas
sur le socle le plus rapide mais une
fois de plus pour rester cohérent et
dans le milieu de gamme
ça fera parfaitement bien la faire je
jouais notamment à call of duty dessus
en qualité graphique moyenne
eh bien ça fonctionne et c'est pas la
meilleure expérience mais une fois de
plus on reste sur une tablette milieu de
gamme d'eau qu'on aura pour son argent
la question de l'autonomie est très
intéressante parce qu'on a une très
grosse batterie de 7000 40 millions
terreur qui vous permettra d'aller
suffisamment nous alors on va pas le
mesurer comme un smartphone en disant
qu'on peut garder un jour et demi deux
jours parce qu'on normalement n'est pas
autant dans sa tablette que sur son
smartphone vous pourrez donc le garder
suffisamment longtemps une dizaine
d'heures en vision
en fonction de vos besoins en fonction
de vos usages en cours de ce que vous
allez en faire vous avez de la recharge
rapide en usb c'est une fois de plus on
s'inscrit dans l'idée du milieu de gamme
avec une tablette qui vous satisfera qui
fera plein de choses pour vous sans
faire des miracles pour la question de
l'ouest on tourne ici sur when you had
deux points bonne nouvelle ça marche
bien j'aime beaucoup basé sur android
disent rien d'exceptionnel à vous dire
là dessus par contre j'aimerai quelque
chose de très bizarre c'est au niveau de
netflix qui est pourtant préinstallé
lorsque j'ouvrirai netflix samedi que je
dois mettre à jour mon d'applications
pour continuer lorsque je clique sur ok
sa marque cette application n'est plus
compatible avec mon appareil faut
contacter les développeurs pour en
savoir plus
alors moi je veux bien contacter le
développeur je clique là mais si vous
voulez envoyer un email à netflix pour
savoir ce qui se passe avec votre
tablette
ça peut rapidement être compliqué je
vous avoue que tout de suite les alors à
laquelle fait cette vidéo j'ai pas de
réponse à vous apporter
j'ai regardé ce qu'on peut trouver sur
d'autres médias et j'ai vu des tests ou
netflix fonctionner donc ça veut dire
que les flics ce moment ou un autre a
été fonctionnelle est ce qu'il y à une
mise à jour de one day ou je ne sais
quoi qui empêchent cette version donne
explique de fonctionner et est-ce que
potentiellement une mise à jour
permettra à l'application de fonctionner
à nouveau sur cette tablette je pense
que c'est un petit peu ça je ne
comprendrais pas que netflix ne soit pas
compatible sur la galaxy tab est si elle
ait ça serait surprenant donc je pense
que c'est une question de versions
question tant une question de mise à
jour d'ailleurs si vous comment vous
regardez cette vidéo vous avez acheté
cette tablette peut marquer en bas en
commentaire savoir s'ils mettent flex
fonctionne chez vous sur ce modèle là
puisque l'on pour l'instant -
malheureusement c'est pas possible de là
on se retrouve à l'arrière avec un seul
capteur photo c'est un capteur de 8
mégapixels une ouverture ici de f1
points 9
il n'y a absolument aucun flash led ici
on peut faire de la vidéo en 1080p /
souhaite jeter à 30 fps
il ya l'avant vous avez une petite
caméra de sel fiq est planqué ici c'est
une caméra de 5 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.0 la question est est ce qu'on achète
une tablette comme ça pour faire de la
vidéo pour faire la photo pour ce film
et variés souvenir pour moi la réponse
est non donc la partie photo vidéo j'ai
envie de dire on pas simple à côté si
vous voulez faire des belles photos des
mails vidéos
prenez votre smartphone sera toujours
mieux maintenant le truc qui est
intéressant c'est ça et ça c'est lui
espère alors le s pen il à 4096 points
de pression ça sera un grand classique
il a une pointe de 0,7 mm vous en
rendrez pas con comme ça je n'ai pas
mesuré mais a priori ce que nous dit
samsung et les une latence de 26 mm
quand j'ai vu l'arrivée de ce produit
quand j'ai vu le positionnement
tarifaire show supposer une question je
me suis dit pourquoi est ce que j'irai
acheter une samsung galaxy tab et ce
this light alors que je peux acheter la
samsung galaxy tab est 5e compliqué avec
les noms light le essentiel like you lie
bon lite on comprend que je me suis donc
dit pourquoi est-ce que j'ai acheté ce
modèle là alors que je peux avoir la
galaxy tab est 5e avec un écran amoled
avec un poubelle écran avec une
meilleure expérience multimédia
quasiment d'un prix même si la galaxy
tab et 5 est un peu plus cher que la
samsung galaxy tab et 6 light elle
faillit sas tient à pas grand chose dit
un fonctionnaire vendeur on peut la
trouver un tarif qui serait sensiblement
le même
et bien la différence elle se situe ici
dans ce petit accessoire puisque wii
avec votre samsung galaxy tab et 6 et
lite vous pouvez faire de la prise de
notes vous pouvez venir dessiner
pourrait venir contrôler votre tablette
avec votre espèce et ça apporte une
autre touche que n'a pas la samsung
galaxy tab est 5e
ce style et vous permet de faire quand
même pas mal de choses vous avez
notamment pouvoir venir ici créer une
note affichée les notes sélection
intelligente de faire des captures
d'écran si vous le souhaitez des
messages animé dr doodle peine de
rajouter des raccourcis ce sont des
choses qu'on trouve déjà chez samsung
mais c'est bien qu'un modèle light à
moins de 500 euros vous permettent de le
faire on peut faire de tic-tac-toe et on
peut faire plein de jeux sympas on a
beaucoup de solutions
il ya regardez je suis presque très très
bon j'avais moi même le challenge
lorsque votre tablette est éteinte et
bien vous n'avez qu'à venir appuyer sur
votre bouton et vous pouvez venir
ensuite 30 des notes extrêmement
facilement un petit coucou est de mise
ça c'est chouette on peut même faire des
jolis coeurs bien évidemment avec ce
joli style et pourrait devenir
complètement contrôler votre tablette
naviguer facilement ouvrir des réglages
changer faire ce que vous voulez bon il
ya un côté très pratique
ça vient peut remplacer votre bois c'est
votre doigt mais en mode un peu moins
sale mais surtout pour toutes les
personnes qui veulent s'essayer au
dessin ce que c'est vraiment pour moi
l'intérêt qu'ils veulent venir faire un
peu de photoshop
alors attention on n'est pas non plus
sur une bête de compet mais si vous
voulez faire un peu de dessin un peu de
retouches photo ou que sais-je encore
d'ailleurs dit moi vous tous vous faites
avec votre stylet pour bien marquer
maintenant on bat en commentaire et bien
vous pouvez le faire avec ça ça vient
augmenter l'expérience donc ça pour moi
aussi c'est un excellent parcours
samsung alors attention ici c'est pas un
style et bluetooth
vous n'avez donc pas de navigation par
gps pour venir avancées pour venir
naviguer comme vous l'avez notamment sur
la galaxy tab l6 ne peut pas tout avoir
ça ça me paraît quand même relativement
normal vous
- votre petit bouton qui vous permet
lorsque vous appuyez dessus et bien
devenir go mais on peut faire pas mal de
choses à des gonds ce traître à tourner
je dirais que si vous voulez aller
encore plus loin encore augmenter
l'expérience et bien des gens va
commencer par recadrer ça ça serait
quand même beaucoup plus sympa je pense
que vous en dites moi si je vous qu'un
drame allait bien ça va pas être cool
soyez sérieux comme ça voilà c'est hier
à peu près si vous voulez encore
augmenter l'expérience ce qu'il vous
faudrait et bien c'est un petit clavier
bluetooth mais après ce sera compliqué à
transporter alors déjà que lorsque vous
prenez votre soupe distiller up et vous
le posez comme ça si vous faites pas
attention et bien un moment ça peut
venir des tâches et même si l'aspect
magnétique est quand même très fort et
le tient vraiment bien il vous faudrait
en plus une petite cover pour bien
protéger derrière vous avez une sur le
site de samsung qui est bien qui vous
permet de glisser sa très facilement
donc d'éviter de le perdre
ça va surtout vous protéger l'écran donc
c'est aussi très important bon je pense
que ça peut valoir un coup et coûte
d'ailleurs 69 euros 90 ailleurs si ces
produits vous intéresse je vous ai mis
des liens en bas dans la description
vous pouvez y aller vous faudrait donc
la cover au plus il vous faudrait un
petit clavier bluetooth la voulte
transformé par nos ordinateurs
en tout cas où vous commencez à vous
rapprocher de certaines fonctionnalités
on va pas non plus tout faire avec ce
produit 1 vous avez notamment pas de n97
est ce que vous avez réellement besoin
d'avoir du 11e ci dessus je suis pas
convaincu vous n'avez pas non plus de
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour le
déverrouiller très facilement ce soit
sur le côté que ce soit au dos que ce
soit au niveau de l'écran vous n'en avez
pas vous avez ici du faceen locke c'est
parce qu'elle est plus sécurisé mais ça
fonctionnera et si vous avez vraiment
peur et bien à ce moment là vous faites
un petit schéma vous faites un code pin
ce que vous voulez ça peut bien vous
rassurer on le voit on n'est pas sur un
produit parfait on est sur un produit
milieu de gamme qui coûte 399 euros et
je trouve que vu le positionnement vu
les finitions vue produit surtout vu le
stylet et les usages que vous pourriez
en avoir avec et bien c'est pas mal mais
il existe également une version 4g si
vous voulez mettre votre carte sim à 469
euros est ce que ça vaut vraiment le
coup aujourd'hui acheter une version 4g
alors que vous pouvez faire du partage
de connexion avec vos smartphones je
vous laisse y répondre au commentaire
vous avez cinq minutes en tout cas moi
je suis pas persuadé je pense que déjà à
399 euros vous avez une tablette qui
sera très bonne pour usage multimédia
qui sera pratique pour la prise de notes
qui sera pas idéal pour de la présidente
on amphithéâtre sans clavier bluetooth
ça pourrait être un petit peu
le côté un peu négatif pour ajouter
également une expérience productivité
vous faut bien évidemment un clavier
bluetooth pour tout ce qui va être
multimédia la maison pour tous qui va
être gestion bureautique petit
bureautique et bien vous avez un produit
qui est pas mal qu'elle ya fait [ __ ]
sympathique voilà ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui pour samsung galaxy tab est
is light a vous de me dire maintenant
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas au
commentaire vous habite bien évidemment
à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas
parce qu'encore plein de chose qui
arrive quand on parle de teck
regardez j'ai notamment salah qui est
planqué la regardez là je montre un peu
les coulisses le temps de découvrir tout
ça là alors je parle pas du vélo je
parle juste derrière c'est une dernière
télé qu l'aide
huit cas de samsung 65 pouces on s'en
parle extrêmement ans bientôt dont vous
invite bien évidemment à vous abonner
pour tout savoir sur ce je vous embrasse
nous avons beaucoup d'amour plein de
câlins arrivé en sorte ça fait longtemps
qu'on s'est passé un cap
bien bien de la recommencer votre côté
mignon s'est bien passé le confinement
première fois bon bon parfait allez
bisous a très bien quelqu'un
[Musique]